President-Elect Donald Trump
will be taking office
immediately
and then heading off
to vacation this weekend,
but he's already got his eye
on 2020.
In an interview
with the Washington Post,
Trump said
he's looking forward
to trademark his next campaign
slogan, which is not gonna be,
"Do svidaniya,
American comrades."
-(laughter)
-It's...
In 2020, he plans to run
with "Keep America Great,"
showing just how confident he is
that there will still be
an America
-in four years.
-Nah. -(laughter)
But people online
were quick to point out
that they'd heard that phrase
somewhere before.
Oh, yes. "Keep America Great"
was the tagline
for the third installment
-of The Purge: Election Year.
-Oh, my God.
(laughter, applause
and cheering)
But at least he has a consistent
vision for this country.
-So comedians...
-(laughter and groaning)
...since that motto might need
to change, what's another
movie-inspired slogan
for Trump's 2020 campaign?
-Bryan. -You want the truth?
I can't handle the truth.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: All right. Very good.
-(applause)
-Points.
Very good.
Erin Gibson.
I'm just a girl
standing in front of a boy,
asking him to please not
get us into a war with China.
-(laughter, applause, cheering)
-All right, points. Points.
-Judah Friedlander.
-Uh,
Toto, we're not in Kansas.
Uh, we're in Canada.